the German government has agreed to buy
out almost all shares of the private gas
utility Juniper effectively
nationalizing the company
it's the latest twist in a month-long
Saga that began with Russian moves to
slash the delivery of pipeline gas
Juniper is said to have a new majority
owner the German government which has
bought out Finnish state-owned Energy
company fought to him and now holds 98.5
percent of shares
Juniper had been caught up in the
ongoing energy crisis after Russia
stopped almost all natural gas flows to
Germany in response to sanctions over
the war in Ukraine
to deliver on its long-term contracts
Juniper had to buy gas elsewhere at much
higher prices this led to a devastating
loss of 12 billion euros during the
first half of the year and it will lead
to further losses down the road
Juniper is not the only Energy company
facing losses as a general measure to
prop up the sector the German government
was looking to in-state a levy on gas
close to two and a half cents per
kilowatt hour to be paid by consumers it
is now unclear if that's still possible
with juniper being nationalized the
government would end up getting the
money that gas consumers paid with the
levy on gas that means it wouldn't be a
levy anymore but attacks and the
government can only impose taxes under
very specific circumstances which don't
apply here
so after nationalization and another 8
billion euros provided more money might
be needed to keep Juniper afloat it's
just part of the price for Germany's
long dependency on cheap Russian gas
you know
Hans peterborghoff researches financial
markets at hohenheim University he joins
me now from Stuttgart Hans Peter welcome
to the show you followed the banking
crisis more than a decade ago when
States cited the system relevance of
private businesses as a reason to
intervene is that same rationale also
Justified here
yes it's Justified and it's even more so
Justified because I mean a banking cries
is a bad thing but you can get out of it
on your own here we have a kind of War
policies and more economic policies
which are necessary we have to keep the
backbone of our economy running
otherwise we don't have the economic
Force to get through the difficult times
in front of us so the state must
guarantee this although for sure State
ownership is not of an efficient very
efficient form of ownership usually
as you just observed banks in that case
return to profitability rather fast in
this case it might be different is this
a stewardship or is it going to be a
genuine State ownership for quite a Time
in the past in many places as well
became a permanent ownership I think
that's not a good idea so many many
institutions have type State under State
Control in many countries and became
very inefficient so I think we should
have a perspective to get rid of this
state ownership as
the moment it gets possible again with
regard to war situation in the East End
the general situation on the global
market for energy
do you think however it could be hard
for the state to back out now that it's
in
well I
guess gas supply in a way that the
industry has enough gas and that at
least people don't freeze to death and
we must be all able to organize this
shortage of gas in an efficient and a
fast way particularly uh in the long run
however I I'm very much aware of when
the state comes in the other criterias
which are not the economist criterias
which for example bring people into
board positions things like that
politics plays a role than that so in
the long run this is not an efficient
way to organize things but a war as we
have in Europe at the moment is not a
very efficient thing anyway we lose a
lot of efficiency due to these War
there's a plan for uh Germany to pass
along a lot of the costs that these
utilities were facing a gas surcharge to
come into effect in the coming days if
Germany ends up taking over some of
these companies such as Juniper will be
harder to ask gas consumers to
essentially foot the bill for nationally
owned utilities
dad ly it might also be not legally
feasible because as as you mentioned
before it becomes a kind of attacks in a
way it's also a bit unfair because I
mean the people who took gas as their
energy didn't know about these risks and
now they have to bear the risk and have
to wear the costs carry the cost of this
special risk the same could have
happened in a different geopolitical
situation with oil or any other kind of
energy except for sure the renewable
energies so I think also this kind of
pushing all the costs on the on the gas
consumers looks not very fair
all right Hans peterborgoff at hornheim
University in Stuttgart thank you very
much
pleasure